a massive coveted relief bill includes
billions in waste and nonsense
attorney general bill bahr says he's not
going to appoint an election fraud
special counsel
and anthony fauci says we should keep
everything shut down but also keep
importing people from the uk
despite a possible new virus strain i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
stop that get protected at
expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news of the day in
just one moment first let us
remind you that you are spending way too
much money on your cell phone bill you
could be getting exactly the same sort
of coverage for probably half the price
with pure talk
usa you could be saving over 800 a year
just by switching
to pure talk usa from verizon at t
t-mobile think about it what could your
family do with an extra 800 bucks you
don't even have to sacrifice coverage as
i say pure talk has the same coverage
same bars as one of the big carriers but
they're charging
you half you definitely have to don't
have to sacrifice customer service
either their team is based
right here in the united states some of
the nicest people you will ever talk to
get unlimited talk text and two gigs of
data for just 20 bucks a month if you go
over on data usage well they're not
going to charge you for it so
that's great i mean here's the thing
most of these other big cell phone
companies they are charging you for a
limited talk
and text and unlimited data you are not
using unlimited data so you are paying
for stuff
you are not using if that makes you feel
good then i guess continue doing it if
you'd like to save money
for a program you will actually use go
to pure talk at usa grab your mobile
phone
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro when you
do
you save 50 off your very first month
style pound 250 say keyword ben shapiro
to get started pure talk is simply
smarter wireless check them out right
now again grab that mobile phone
now pound 250 say ben shapiro okay so
last night the congress passed
overwhelmingly
a one trillion dollar coveted relief
package it actually passed
by in the senate a 92-6 vote the six
republicans who voted against and this
should give you an idea
of exactly what's wrong with the bill
i'm marcia blackburn rick scott of
florida ron johnson wisconsin mike lee
of utah
rand paul of kentucky and ted cruz of
texas which is to say the most
conservative members of the senate voted
against
the bill mainly because the bill is as
all giant bills are a crap sandwich
and naturally the media celebrate the
crap sandwich so first of all a couple
of things are worthy of note a lot of
the stuff that you're hearing about what
the bill
is for and how it doesn't provide enough
relief to people it's not actually true
okay so you're hearing right now for
example that people only got 600
in relief that is not correct okay
stimulus checks
ernie tedeschi who's a former u.s
treasury economist
is a good threat on twitter pointing out
that people are just getting this wrong
they're saying oh well you know it's
only six hundred dollars in relief
that's all we get after all
okay first of all before we even get to
the problem with that argument
let us point out that there is a solid
case to be made that the federal
government should not even be providing
relief at this point considering
how widely disparate various states are
in their lockdown regimens at the
beginning
when everybody was locked down when the
federal government was encouraging all
states to shut down there was a good
case to be made
that maybe the federal government needed
to bail everybody out we are now nine
months into this thing florida
is wide open okay places like north
dakota are wide open
there are lots of places that have said
you can still do business north dakota
right now
still has an unemployment rate of i
believe well under four percent
meanwhile places like new york have like
a 15 unemployment rate because they shut
down and they never started
not shutting down the same thing
happened in california so having north
dakota
bail out california and new york based
on their different shutdown regimens
doesn't make a whole hell of a lot of
sense the counter argument
would be that the federal government is
still encouraging place-by-place
shutdowns that this is based mostly on
data which i kind of don't believe
as opposed to politics but there's a
solid case to be made
that really if california wants to
increase its unemployment benefits and
take out more debt in order to do that
it should go ahead and do that and new
york should do the same
and that's a new york and a california
problem that is not really like a kansas
problem okay but putting that complaint
aside which i think
there's some truth to that and also
putting aside the fact that what you
actually want to do is encourage people
to get back to work if they are young
and they are healthy and it has been
insipid from the very start
to suggest that the work rules should be
the same for a 65 year old person with
diabetes
as they are for a 21 year old fresh out
of college putting all of those policies
aside and talking about just what is in
the relief bill
and with the understanding that there
are a ton of people who are out of work
who should not be out of work and who do
need the relief at least in this moment
and this is sort of emergency spending
a lot of the lies that are being told
about this bill are in fact lies so for
example
again people suggesting there's only six
hundred dollars in coveted relief
in this bill that is not correct ernest
she says stimulus checks are only around
one-fifth of the total bill
unemployment insurance in america
typically pays around 50 of pre-layoff
wages
though it does vary state by state with
this extra 300 bucks a week that will be
about 85 percent there's unemployment
insurance in the bill
as well okay so you're mostly being
filled in via your state unemployment
as well as now the federal unemployment
if you're unemployed you get an extra 1
per month through mid-march if you're a
gig worker or you've been out of work
since early 2020 that's on top of having
your
your unemployment insurance benefits
extended the bill includes another 300
billion dollars in
in paycheck protection program loans the
ppp loans which are essentially payroll
support for small business
right in order for those loans to be
forgiven you have to just pass that
money right through to employees
even if your business is not currently
open i've actually thought that that was
a bad idea from the start because you're
basically
using these various businesses as
pass-throughs for direct aid instead of
just signing people checks you're now
telling a business that they have to
keep on paying all of the expenses of
employees
who when the economy recovers may not be
coming back at all
but that isn't the bill if a business
wants all of these loans fully forgiven
they essentially have to maintain their
employment and wages which is
effectively the equivalent
100 payroll support so if you work at
one of these places
and you are getting money through ppp
and you're also getting a track then
you're
in many cases making more than you were
when you were actually working at these
places according to ernie tadeshi
he points out the problem with the us
response originally was not its initial
generosity we actually did a hell of a
lot more than just 1200
checks back in march again this is a
very twitter talking point is the idea
that
over the course of the year you only got
1800 from the government since march
that is not true
in any way shape or form unemployment
insurance has been going for
literally tens of millions of people in
the united states since the beginning
of the pandemic he points out we
probably did more than any other
advanced economy besides canada
even adjusting for the pre-existing
safety net the problem instead is that
the u.s leaned heavily on that
unemployment insurance system to deliver
aid and that was inconsistent it was
cranky some people didn't get the checks
when they needed to right that is a
problem with the general government aid
system but that is not a problem with
what congress did okay so
this was an awful lot of aid right i
mean there's a lot of money
in this particular bill and so people
who are complaining that there was not
very much money
in the particular bill are just wrong
about this senator john kennedy from
louisiana
points out correctly he says you know
you guys are complaining there wasn't
enough money we're spending a trillion
dollars for goodness sake and we spent
like seven trillion dollars earlier this
year here is kennedy
on fox news is this real help or is this
just
optics for senators in washington to
make it look like they're bringing real
help to the american people which is it
oh it's real help it's a trillion
dollars for god's sakes
uh what is that one 000 million dollars
and uh there is no money ferry we we
don't have this money
we only have five percent of it sandra
we had to borrow it it's real help
will it be enough i think it will be but
we're just gonna have to wait and see
okay so there there are a couple of
other things that were passed at the
same time
the the continuing resolution to fund
the government was passed at the same
time there were also some defense bills
that were
passed at the same time as this giant
bill basically in a last minute
of legislation congress just passed
through thousands of pages of
legislation which is really the bigger
issue with this particular
with this particular passage right there
are problems with the bill for sure
we're going to go through all of them
the bigger problem is that there are
problems now with every bill because the
only way legislation gets done
is it basically gets done
through a congress that is generally
constipated until there's a blowout
that's basically the way it works you
reach a deadline and then congress just
out like a 5 000 page bill and then
everybody is forced to vote on it within
about 30 seconds
so they do nothing for six months and
then just they've colon then
out comes a giant horrible that is
filled with
some good things but a lot of crap and
then you are supposed to be like oh well
i'm so glad that congress is here to
save
all of us one uh by the way quick notion
when i say that they passed a bunch of
bills including the continuing
resolution if on the government
as well as this giant trillion dollar
relief package they also passed this
defense
bill right that defense bill is the one
that actually includes the foreign aid
for israel so you're seeing on twitter
this this trending idea that 500 million
dollars in aid were contained in the
coveted relief bill that is not true
congress passed a suite of bills
including coveted relief and the bill
funding the defense department for 2021
which also includes
foreign aid as jair rosenberg of tablet
magazine points out it doesn't matter
a lot of the a lot of the people who
aren't super friendly to israel on
twitter started passing that around to
naturally it trended on twitter last
night it is worth debunking that notion
thoroughly we'll get to more of the
debunking in just a second we'll talk
about what is in here and whether
republicans should vote for it they're
people who are urging trump to veto it
he's not going to veto this bill i mean
that's just not going to happen not when
there are this many people who are
hurting
but we will get to this in just one
second first let us talk
about quality watches so would you like
like a great quality watch at a price
that is not going to break the bank like
one of these big luxury watches
it can cost you like thousands and
thousands and thousands of dollars how
about like a great looking watch that is
durable
and look i mean really looks great you
wouldn't know how much it costs and it's
not going to cost you a fortune i am
talking of course
about ventura check this baby out this
is a nice ventura watch it's a
chronometer that means that it has the
seconds hand you can put timers on it
and everything really good stuff
vincero is dedicated to the craft they
put the time and effort into crafting
timepieces so you can wear them
day after day they are giving my
listeners exclusive access to their end
of the year sale head over to
venturawatches.com
shapiro start your year off looking
great and feeling confident trust me i
talk about this brand
because i believe in the products they
make i've given vincero watches to
pretty much everybody
in my family you know a lot of members
of my family have gotten birthday
presents from
vincero and there's a reason for that
with ventura there's no brand name
markup
no big name big time price tags their
promise to you is very easy
solid well-made products you will enjoy
wearing for years to come these guys
know how important it is to shop from
local brands you can trust finchero
offers free shipping 365 day returns
guarantees your watch for five years
these things are durable they believe in
doing things the right way so their
customers get the best
and don't have to settle my listeners
have been heroes to vincero all this
year
the folks at vincero told me they are
extremely grateful for all the support
we here at the show
are grateful you support our sponsors
head on over to venturawatches.com
shapiro for their end of the year sale
that is v-i-n-c-e-r-o-watches.com
shapiro go to my link and pick out your
favorite watching at a great discount
right now it makes an excellent
excellent holiday gifts go check them
out right this very instant okay so
what exactly is let's start at the
beginning what exactly is in this
coveted relief bill according to emily
zenati writing for the daily well
daily wire congress is set to pass two
major spending bills on monday a nearly
one trillion dollar coronavirus relief
bill
and a 1.4 trillion dollar omnibus bill
in a record-setting vote that will fund
hundreds of government programs and
according to lawmakers assist individual
americans struggling to make ends meet
because of kova 19
related restrictions the bill does in
fact contain some help for those facing
economic struggles
in addition to providing a second round
of direct stimulus checks to individual
taxpayers this time 600 bucks
the bill extends federal supplemental
unemployment benefits right that is the
really big check it's not the 600
check it is the extension of federal
supplemental unemployment benefits
the jobless as well as gig employees
experiencing a slowdown in business
can now get an extra 300 bucks per week
through march through mid-march so if
you are on
unemployment insurance you're really
talking about like an eighteen hundred
dollar
check every month you're not talking
about six hundred dollars i'm at
eighteen hundred dollars
and that is on top of whatever state aid
you are getting as well
the coronavirus relief package expands
paycheck protection as well opening up
248 billion dollars in funding for loans
to struggling businesses
even as evidence emerges that millions
from the first round of ppp loans went
to connected
corporations this is of course the great
risk of all of these bills
as they turn into cronyism and they're
packed jam-packed with like a bunch of
crap that doesn't mean
anything this time around the covet 19
build contains special grounds for
specific industries
20 billion dollars for businesses in low
income communities 15 billion dollars
for struggling live venues
movie theaters and museums i'm not sure
it is worthwhile bailing out movie
theaters to be perfectly frank with you
and this comes as from somebody who
loves movie theaters i love movie
theaters
my wife and i used to go on lots of
dates to movie theaters before
the covet shutdown happened i love
seeing
movies in the theater i think it's a
great tragedy that this may be a
communal experience that goes the way
the dodo bird
but i don't know why we're spending 15
billion to bail out movie theaters
not given the fact that you've got
places like hbo max that have already
explained that they are going to
simultaneously release things in
theaters and at home which means that
people are just not going to go to
theaters i think that
movie theater is going to be the last
thing to come back and it's going to
become more of a specialty thing i don't
think you're going to see movie theaters
on you know every other corner of the
way that you used to there are a number
of breaks for businesses according to
emily
some of which haven't gone over well on
social media
the relief bill includes a two-year tax
break for business meals this is a
priority for president trump apparently
and rolls over a variety of temporary
tax breaks
known as extenders for some for multiple
years the business meal deduction has
been labeled the three martini lunch
deduction that very few people aside
from key democratic legislators
in major cities are having many dining
luncheons as
emily zinnati suggests the bill also
helps renters there's a 25 billion
dollar assistance
program and a continued eviction
moratorium under the coven 19 relief
deal 13 billion
will go to food benefits 15 billion to a
program for direct payments to farmers
to assist in keeping american food
production
afloat well i wasn't aware that we had
like a problem in keeping american food
production afloat considering that
demand
is still kind of the same in the
american food markets it's just going
through different channels just not
going through restaurants there are big
handouts in the bill
airlines get 15 billion again i'm not
sure that that is worthwhile i'm not
sure the taxpayer
should be paying out airlines who've
experienced this shock
and setback you don't want them going
bankrupt you want them still existing
obviously but
it seems to me that airlines it's going
to be a while before people are
traveling in quite the way that
they used to people are not going to
travel casually quite as easily for
probably a couple of years particularly
if you're elderly
airports are going to get 2 billion
amtrak is going to get a billion dollars
so
i guess that leaves joe biden and pete
booty just particularly happy very very
romantic amtrak
higher education is gonna get 82 billion
dollars
higher education should receive zero
dollars okay they should not receive 82
billion dollars
higher education is wildly overpriced
it's been pushed up
in the marketplace by federal loans in
the first place there's a good case to
be made that
huge swaths of higher education should
be left on the cutting room floor
including
many of the what we would call north
campus majors at ucla the liberal arts
majors should be left on the cutting
room floor
i do not know why we are dumping out 82
billion dollars to
higher education particularly at a time
when you are looking at places like
harvard that have billion dollar
endowments that makes no sense to me the
us postal service
also wins big congress used the bill to
forgive a 10 billion
loan to the u.s postal service a loan
they gave to the service in an earlier
coronavirus relief bill
usps has no hope of ever paying back
states will get 20 billion to help
purchase vaccines and distribute them
they also get 20 billion to help with
expanding covet 19 testing
they don't get a bailout for the
economic damage they've incurred during
the extended
virus lockdown democrats pushed for that
republicans said no
on the other hand republicans were
pushing for a limit to legal liability
for corporations
based on covid right if they said you
need to come to work if you're not sick
and then people came to work and they
were sick
people were gonna sue these corporations
apparently they still can theoretically
there are further expenditures that are
now coming to light apparently
the final draft of the bill contains a
number of handouts for congress
including a provision paying for the
additional pandemic expenditures
incurred by the congressional day care
center ooh sounds great
and 5 million bucks to protect members
from the coronavirus by expanding
testing and increasing the budget
of the congressional physician also the
washington dc government
got 38 million in reimbursements for its
work controlling protests and providing
security i just why
did they do a good job with that did i
miss the part where the washington dc
government did a fantastic job
controlling protests and providing
security
when people were literally running
through downtown washington you see just
breaking store windows
that that seems like a waste of money as
well we'll get to
more of what is in the bill and why it
is that congress again has colon
when it comes to these bills we'll get
to that in just one second first
let's talk about a basic responsibility
you have you have a basic responsibility
as a human being to ensure that god
forbid something happens to you
your family is taken care of and this is
why you need life insurance but
if you need life insurance and don't
want to deal with the hassle or expense
you need to try policy genius policy
genius combines a cutting edge insurance
marketplace
with help from licensed experts to save
you time and save you money right now
it could save 50 or more by using policy
genius to compare life insurance when
you're shopping for a policy that could
last for more than a decade the savings
really do start to add up here's how it
works first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
you can compare quotes from top insurers
and find your best price policy genius
will compare policies starting at as
little as one dollar a day you might
even be eligible to skip that in-person
medical exam once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape the best
part they work for you not the insurance
company so if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process
they'll take care of everything that
kind of services earn policy genius a
five-star rating
across over 1600 reviews on trustpilot
and google so
if you have loved ones who depend on
your income don't go into the next year
without life insurance go to
policygenius.com get started you could
say 50
or more by comparing quotes start the
new year with one less thing to worry
about policy genius when it comes to
insurance it is nice and quite important
to get it right okay so a couple of
things to note here
nancy pelosi was considered the master
negotiator throughout this entire
process
she turned down a deal that was
literally twice this size just a couple
of months ago before the election
steve mnuchin went to her and he's like
i will give you 1.8 trillion dollars and
she was like
no there's an election
and now she's out there championing the
bill because she's actually terrible at
her job
i mean truly awful at her job which is
probably why only a bare majority of
democratic voters actually want to see
her continue as speaker of the house
here she was saying six hundred dollars
in relief is significant so she's trying
to uh
to gloss over the fact that she
completely blew this negotiation
we also have in the legislation
uh direct payments which were not in the
republican bill
to america's working families i would
like them
bigger but they are uh significant
and they will be going out soon by the
way she was asked directly by the media
this morning
why exactly she didn't just go along
with mnuchin's 1.8 trillion dollar bill
and she couldn't give a good answer we
all know the answer she was trying to
hold up covered relief until
after the election we all know why this
bill got done now the reason the bill
got done now
is because democrats believed from
election night on that they could now
pass the covered relief bill without
doing any damage
to joe biden or helping donald trump
they were afraid of passing the coveted
relief bill before
the election because it might alleviate
people's financial fears
and lead to more votes for donald trump
so instead they held up the aid that you
needed for political purposes this is
perfectly obvious steve mnuchin for his
part the treasury
secretary he says the 600 payments are
going to arrive after christmas
as you know we've been working on for
months additional
money for those parts of the economy and
we couldn't be more pleased that we got
this done in time
for the end of the year the president
wanted direct payments
so we will be sending out next week
direct deposit i expect we'll get the
money out by the beginning of next week
twenty four hundred dollars for a family
of four so much needed relief
it just in time for the holidays okay so
that is getting done now there's a bunch
of crap in here right and
for the only time this is this is where
you have the the online meme the worst
person you know just made an excellent
point
heartbreaking right alexander
ocasio-cortez actually tweeted out
something correct i know it's shocking
to me too
yesterday she tweeted out this is why
congress needs time to actually read
this package before voting on it members
of congress have not read this bill it's
over 5000 pages arrived at 2pm today we
are told to expect to vote on it
in two hours this isn't governance it's
hostage taking she happens to be exactly
correct about this
okay this is right and you know who
agrees with this
she should continue she said by the way
it's not just members who need to see
the bill ahead of time you do the public
needs to see these bills with enough
time to contact the representative
to let them know they feel members are
reeling right now because they don't
have time to consult with their
communities
she again this is right this is correct
you know who agrees with this probably
the most one of the most conservative
members of the united states senator
mike of the united states senate mike
lee from utah he tweeted out this is the
spending bill under consideration in
congress today i received it just
moments ago and will likely be asked to
vote on it late tonight
it is 5593 pages long i know there's
some good things in it i'm equally
confident that there are bad things in
it here's the really sad thing we're
being told there will be no opportunity
to amend or improve it
as a result nearly every member of
congress house and senate democrat or
republican will have been excluded from
the process of developing this bill
which will cost american taxpayers
trillions of dollars this process by
which members of congress are asked to
refer blindly to legislation
negotiated entirely in secret by four of
their colleagues must come
to an end it won't come to an end until
no longer works for those empowered by
it that can happen
but only when most members of both
houses and both political parties stop
voting for bills they haven't read and
by design cannot read until after it's
too late
well he happens to be right also this is
not going to change it's not this is the
way governance is done now and the
reason that governance is done
this way now there are a couple reasons
for this so the more cynical
have suggested that one of the reasons
that you end up with these giant
omnibus packages that nobody ever reads
is because we
got rid of what are called the earmarks
so earmarks were the
atrocious congressional behavior whereby
a bill would
basically be put forward and then a
bunch of members would say okay you know
what i'm not voting for that bill unless
you give me a little giveaway for my
district right the robert byrd memorial
bridge
in west virginia right you would get
this is how you get highways named after
senators right is the senator would say
i'm not going to pass this defense
authorization act unless we put in this
hundred thousand dollar
grant from my local post office with my
name on it okay
that was not great right it was a bad
practice the the problem is you get rid
of that practice
and what you end up with is those
earmarks back in the bill but not as
earmarks
they used to be done as amendments and
the nice thing about doing it as
amendments is that it would then be
exposed to the light of day
is that you would have people offer an
amendment saying i want my hundred
thousand dollar post office and people
like that's stupid
you need to vote for it anyway but now
it just gets done behind closed doors so
now
it's like they roll out a six thousand
page bill and it has all the same pork
it's just not exposed to the light of
day
in quite the same way so you're getting
the same amount of pork it's just not
being done as quote unquote earmarks
and and so you don't get to see how the
sausage is made and one of the nice
things about congress is you're supposed
to see
how the sausage is made it also happens
to be the case that it's long-standing
congressional practice to now wrap
everything up into a giant ball so that
nobody is answerable for any specific
piece of legislation
you know people have asked me what sort
of constitutional amendment would i
favor i'm generally not in favor of
giant wide-scale changes to the
constitution one constitutional
amendment that i would favor is that
every bill has to be five pages
and it has to be it has to come with a
codicil in plain language right there
actually has to be some sort of
explanation what exactly is going on
you cannot have 5600 page bills
where nobody knows what's in it because
it creates a perverse incentive on both
sides so here is the perverse incentive
number one perverse incentive number one
is if you don't vote for this relief
package then you are labeled as twitter
is currently doing
somebody awful right this is why aoc you
can tell the difference between those
who are principled and those who are not
on this particular issue
aoc said i don't like that they
presented this bill to me
two hours before the vote she then voted
for the bill mike lee
said i don't like how they presented
this bill to me and then he voted
against the bill
so on the one hand what you get and i
understand both positions on that by the
way
i do like i can't believe i'm turning
into a bit of an aoc defender here but
it actually is kind of true
the fact is if you don't vote for the
bill and bill quote unquote does good
things
they then use this in your future
election as a way to browbeat you
so unless you are in a deep blue
district or a deep red state
you have to vote for stuff that you
think is going to overall be a good deal
so
all you every sandwich is a crap
sandwich every single sandwich there has
never been and will never be again
just a plain good bill it's not going to
exist instead you're just going to get
these crap sandwich
cram downs by the leaders in the senate
and the house and everybody's either
going to have to vote up or they're
going to have to vote down on it
and you can see why again there's a long
political history in the united states
of people
saying you know what i i think there's
more crap than sandwich in this
particular bill so i'm gonna vote
against it
and then being ripped for voting against
the bill the most obvious example
being barry goldwater in in 1964
he voted against the civil rights act
and then he was ripped up and down
and people suggested that he voted
against the civil rights act because he
was a racist barry goldwater was not a
racist
barry goldwater was was very much
anti-racism goldwater objected to the
titles of the civil rights act that
specifically applied
to private accommodations and to private
businesses and he said overall
i have to vote against the bills i don't
like this provision instead people say
oh well that means he doesn't like civil
rights that's the way the game is played
in congress you pass these giant bills
that are called
coveted relief and then if it includes a
bunch of crap then you are castigated
if you don't vote for it so on the one
hand you're castigated if you don't vote
for it on the other hand
if these bills earn widespread support
you also get to be the congressional
free rider
so to be perfectly cynical about this i
like all of the i know personally all of
the senators who voted against this bill
i totally understand why other senators
voted for the bill and it did provide
them the leeway
to actually vote against the bill i'll
explain in just
one second first let us talk for a
second about the fact that you need
coffee
i need coffee okay i have three children
under the age of seven i get up early
every morning to do the show
and with my kids all night long i need
coffee i didn't used to now i do and
that is why i love
my black rifled coffee black rifle
coffee company ceo and founder evan
hafer
started the business after over 20 years
in the us army as an infantryman
special forces soldier and cia
contractor evan founded black rifle in
along with former army ranger matt best
as the combination of two passions
developing premium fresh roasted coffee
honoring and supporting those who serve
on the front lines black rifle has
donated over 45 000 pounds of coffee or
over 1 million cups of coffee to
soldiers deployed overseas law
enforcement officers wildland
firefighters on the west coast
and medical workers during the coven 19
response just in 2020
alone the best way to enjoy brcc coffee
is through the coffee club it's a free
subscription where your chosen coffee is
roasted
packaged shipped free to your door on
your schedule in addition to convenience
you receive special discounted pricing
gain access to exclusive products
members only content
partner discounts and more get the
freshest coffee coffee in america
without ever leaving your couch if you
want to support their cause by the way i
know the guys who run
excellent excellent dudes go to
blackriflecoffee.com today to get 20
off coffee apparel and gear as well as
20 off your first month
of the coffee club that's
blackriflecoffee.com shapiro for 20 off
coffee apparel and gear
as well as 20 off your first month of
the coffee club at blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro for coffee that is just first
right and you're helping out good folks
blackriflecoffee.com shapiro okay so
as i say because this is the way the
bills get done there is a sort of doubly
edged bad incentive one is to vote for
bad bills because
you don't want to be castigated for not
voting for it the other is to allow free
riders to vote against the bill
in order to uphold their purity of
purpose to the rest of the senate
and now the way the bills normally were
supposed to work and always did
historically
at least for the first hundred years of
the country is that there would be a
single issue bill the single issue bill
would come up
people would vote on the single issue
bill it would either go up or it would
go down and that would be it okay there
was none of this
we're gonna package together 87 000
different topics because first of all
the executive branch is not capable of
handling this stuff
the bigger the government gets the
bigger the executive branch gets the
more congress is going to be
incentivized to blow out the spending
and until the american people stand up
and say we don't like this it's not
going to happen and here's the problem
the american people they kind of do like
this okay the reality is
as much as americans complain about
congress as much as americans
about how the sausage gets made
the reality is when you ask americans
would you like to see the american
government spend less
they say yes and then when you ask them
would you like to see them spend less on
x
people say no no i like x every single
time
every single time every poll shows this
if you ever ask americans
you know you want us generally should
the american government be spending less
and the american people are yeah
absolutely i mean look at the taxes like
this is crazy we're spending four
trillion dollars a year on what on what
and like
well yeah but do you want to see the
federal government spend more on
education you're like yeah that sounds
good i like education books are good
and nobody ever actually examines where
all of this money goes
in the end there are a few members of
congress who like to point this sort of
stuff out
but typically it sort of gets ignored
and the media of course cheer on
all of this stuff the new york times has
this sycophantic piece today titled a
dinner
a deal and moonshine how the stimulus
came together
top party leaders cinched a 900 billion
relief
deal after laying down their swords but
it took an empowered bipartisan group of
moderates to help
bridge the divide now what actually
happened here is the election ended
and then joe biden told the democrats i
don't want to come into office without a
covered relief bill in place so please
just surrender
that's basically what happened here okay
so uh in the end for republicans there's
a better deal for republicans than it
was for democrats okay let's put that
out there
there's a win by mitch mcconnell it is a
negotiating win by mitch mcconnell as
much crap
is in there again i'm just being
realistic there is going to be an
enormous amount of manure
in every congressional bill from now
until the end of time because the
administrative state is too large
because the size of a government is too
large because the american people do not
demand
that their representatives only pass
bills that they can understand
and so this is just going to be the new
normal and it's going to be the new
normal
until the end of time nonetheless this
thing gets passed
the democrats really don't get
everything that they are looking for
here
senator bernie sanders the progressive
independent according to the new york
times had preemptively panned the
emerging framework in part because
checks were not included he locked arms
in the senate with josh hawley of
missouri a conservative
republican in the house representative
pramila jayapal democrat of washington
made a similar stand she texted pelosi
in early december threatening her group
would oppose the stimulus package if it
didn't contain some form
of direct payment senator pat toomey had
other ideas with less than 48 hours
until the government was set to shut
down
toomey stood firm on one demand the
stimulus measure must not only end an
array of programs the fed had created to
help businesses and municipalities
during the pandemic
it must also bar the central bank from
creating anything like them in the
future
but republicans rallied around too many
congressional leaders agreed they would
need to extend
government spending another day to buy
time to resolve the impasse they
ultimately struck an agreement before
midnight
haggling on the floor and in chuck
schumer's suite it took 18 hours before
mcconnell walked down to the senate
floor and announced the deal
okay but you know everybody goes home
happy because they can spend
everybody else's money and money that
has not yet been created
now i've talked about some of the good
stuff that is in here and some of the
stuff that
you know sort of needed to happen but
i've also talked about the fact that
there's an enormous amount of money
that is that is just going to sort of
random crap
so again it was drafted behind closed
doors
fraud and waste have not been
meaningfully addressed as brad palumbo
writes at the free enterprise
institute and he has an entire piece
about this this is the first coven 19
stimulus bill the two trillion dollars
cares act was corrupted by waste fraud
and abuse the federal government sent
more than a million stimulus checks to
dead people
and many more to random european
citizens the expanded unemployment
system it created lost more to fraud
alone
than the entire system paid out in 2019
the paycheck protection program was
swamped with potential fraud
as tens of thousands of ineligible
companies received money
and thousands more were overpaid
none of these problems have been
meaningfully addressed by congress the
latest stimulus effort pours hundreds of
billions of taxpayer money into fraud
right programs without addressing the
problem
and then there's the question as to
whether any of this is going to actually
be
effective now the the fact is that
unfortunately yeah the the only thing
that is going to solve this is getting
out of lockdown
in the end and the paycheck protection
program as i say is not really directed
at preserving businesses it's more being
done as a pass-through but when we talk
about just the pure amount of garbage in
here
like there are certain things that i
think should be legislated on
i just don't know why they aren't a
coveted relief bill so for example
there's an entire section in this
covered relief bill
detailing the reincarnation of the dalai
lama
that that's not a joke the legislation
has summit notable section section 342
of the bill outlines quote a statement
of policy regarding the succession or
reincarnation
of the dalai lama now i actually agree
with the policy here because the policy
basically says that china should have no
role in picking the next dalai lama
and also suggest that we should set up
an embassy in tibet i kind of like all
of those anti-chinese measures
anti-chinese government measures
i'm not sure what they have to do with
covet belief also according to reason
magazine the bill also instructs the
smithsonian institution to create two
new identity-based museums one for women
and one for
latinos the bill also takes a position
on the reincarnation of the dalai lama
but by the way i don't know why we need
a women museum and a latino museum i
understand we have an
uh a national african american history
museum
which was rife with critical race theory
to the point where they actually
released
an exhibit a little earlier this year
that was full of
gems like the suggestion that merit
based
systems and individualism and coming to
work on time were white systems of
privilege and power
i'm not sure why we need more racially
segregated museums i'm not sure why
that's an important thing to be done
at the federal level also it attempts to
normalize u.s relations with sudan
criminalizes illegal streaming and
creates a plan for building a teddy
roosevelt presidential library
in north dakota all of which i think is
vital for people who are out of a job
the bill actually needed to be brought
into the chamber on wheels because again
it is some six thousand pages long other
wonders
the coveted relief bill lays the
groundwork for a quote unquote climate
security advisory council which is
exciting stuff
it also includes 10 million dollars for
gender programs in pakistan
it also makes it illegal to give
racehorses painkillers before training
or racing
which is exciting stuff it provides 40
million to the kennedy center
tom elliott from grabian media has
compiled this list the covered relief
bill creates a commission tasked with
educating consumers
about the dangers associated with using
or storing portable fuel containers for
flammable liquids near an open flame i
mean i wasn't aware that this was a
problem that required
a government solution it seems like if
you don't know not to put you know like
an open gas canister next to an open
flame
then kind of you deserve what you get a
little bit i'm not sure that an
awareness program is going to be all
that helpful
but i suppose you could put that in a
covered i mean what does it have to do
with sure i guess says
no it has nothing to do with covered i
got nothing for you also the coveted
relief bill includes 1.5 million dollars
for the appropriation committee's office
of diversity
and inclusion as well as a bunch of
money for reception so very very
important stuff also the covered relief
bill mandates hiring measures to ensure
diversity in the intelligence community
because i deeply care
whether an analyst is a gay bisexual
transgender little person i really when
they are analyzing incoming
arabic threats i definitely need to know
the identity of the person who's
actually doing
all of that by the way the cover relief
package also includes eight million
dollars to support
the biden presidential transition as
well so lots and lots of stuff
in that coveted relief bill and in the
the coveted package generally
the media are sharing this they wouldn't
have been cheering if it had been passed
under trump because that is the rule
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first
everybody who is a good citizen should
know how to protect themselves with a
gun you should
if you are if you're a good citizen and
you want to protect your family you
should own a gun you should know how to
use
a gun now more than ever emotions are
running high in the country you see it
on the news peaceful protests turning
violent
riots in the streets law enforcement not
staff to handle all emergencies there's
a reason more law-abiding americans are
purchasing guns and making the choice to
protect themselves
and their families if you are a gun
owner however you have to be aware of
self-defense laws where you live it is
not responsible to own a firearm and not
know the legal ramifications
of using it you need the proper
education and industry leading training
to ensure your skills are sharp when
faced with danger plus
the uscca has purchased an insurance
policy that provides the association and
its members with self-defense liability
insurance
in other words go get involved with the
uscca they're doing good stuff every day
get started today text gun 28722 when
you do you'll receive the complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
for free
in this guide you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting
seven firearms drills that could save
your life and much much more it's a
164-page guide
loaded with valuable information go
check them out right now and right now
if you text today
you'll be entered to win one thousand
dollars to put toward a gun of your
choice that you can use to protect your
family text at gun
to 87 222 right now again text gun to 87
222 right now go check out the uscca
okay we're gonna get more
into the covet relief bill the media's
celebration
of it and then we'll get into everything
covid related anthony fauci making some
weird comments about keeping flights
from the uk open
first daily wire we are excited to
announce the historical docu series
apollo 11 what we saw is now available
exclusively for daily wire members
originally released as an audio podcast
for apple and spotify what we saw takes
a detailed look at the apollo 11 mission
to land a man on the moon
it was the culmination of a heated
decades-long space race between cold war
rivals the us and the soviet union
the podcast explores one of america's
greatest accomplishments through the
eyes of the millions of americans who
lived through it
now apollo 11 what we saw is available
to watch as well as listen it's a
beautiful beautiful program i mean like
visually it's really cool
you can check it out over at
dailywire.com or on our apple tv or roku
app the series
is just one piece of all the new content
we have coming down the pipeline
including a new show with candace owens
the entire prageru library a new
entertainment channel we have something
coming next month with the entertainment
channel it's gonna blow you away it's
fantastic
a new investigative journalism team
become a daily wire insider or above
member for 20
off with code watch over at
dailywire.com subscribe make sure to
all of our content downl your big screen
including our podcast and special live
streams that is dailywire.com
subscribe to get 20 off your membership
with codewatch access to all of our new
and existing
content you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
meanwhile obviously the new york times
is chalking up the deal
two wait for it wait for a way for it
joe biden now you got to be asking
yourself what the hell does joe biden
have to do with anything like trump's
the president mitch mcconnell
is running in the senate nancy pelosi
has been the speaker of the house for a
few years here
what in the world are you even talking
about right joe biden is not joe biden
is asleep in his basement he's been
asleep in his basement for two years
i mean you talk about like a rip van
winkle transformation basically joe
biden went to sleep in 2018 and woke up
president
or president-elect supposedly right i
mean that that's that's where things
stand
and the man pretty much was comatose and
then the electoral college elected him
when he won the popular vote by seven
million votes and he's gonna i guess
wake up in the oval office on january
21st
and and he'll already have been given
massive credit for everything we went on
the media's desire to give credit to joe
biden for things he has not done
it is matched only by their desire to
give barack obama credit for a bunch of
things that he never did
either it must be wonderful be to be a
democrat it's like what did you do today
random democrat well i breathed oh
unbelievable breathing you did a great
job breathing
joe biden's main task throughout this
campaign was to basically remain alive
right and we're not talking about like
remain alive in the sense that he was
like in the movie die hard we mean just
remain physically alive that was his
entire task during the campaign
he accomplished this magnificent feat
and the media walked him
into election and now they're
immediately attributing to him god like
powers to get done a covid relief bill
even though he literally has nothing to
do with it because he has no power
because there's only one president at a
time
in the united states but according to
the new york times carl
hulse reporting producing it was a
tortuous time-consuming affair that did
nothing to improve congress's reputation
for his function
but the agreement on a new pandemic aid
package showed the ascendance of
moderates
as a new force in a divided senate and
validated president-elect joseph biden's
belief
it is still possible to make deals on
capitol hill what do you mean
validated his belief you didn't do
anything the hell are you talking about
he's not even president yet what do you
what like
huh along with struggling americans and
businesses the new president was a major
beneficiary of the 900 billion
pandemic stimulus measure that congress
haltingly but finally produced on sunday
and was on track to approve late monday
which will give him some breathing room
when he enters the white house next
month
rather than face an immediate entire
need to act on an emergency economic aid
package
biden and his team can instead take a
moment to try to fashion a more
far-reaching recovery program
and begin to tackle other issues i i do
love how every
here's the way it works whenever
congress passes a bill
and mitch mcconnell is the driving force
behind the bill mcconnell doesn't get
the credit the democrat gets the credit
and then when it turns out that this
bill was a wildly scaled down version
from what democrats were actually
proposing
the media immediately say well this will
provide a model for democrats going
forward
because it's just the beginning of the
ambition no no no you understand
the bill went from large to smaller and
now you are saying that in the future
these bills will go from small
to larger rongo that is not how this is
going to go if republicans hold the
senate if they win those two georgia
senate seats they will be stifling
joe biden's agenda as well they should
and yet the media are like oh my god
look they made a deal that means that
they're going to be able to pass that
climate change legislation
in media land in the land of the new
york times it is always heads democrats
win
tails republicans lose according to the
new york times the group of moderates
was essential to the outcome pushing
senate and house leaders of both parties
into direct personal negotiations they'd
avoided for months demonstrating how
crucial they are likely to be to biden
again this has nothing to do with biden
and mitch mcconnell all the way through
was like oh negotiate with pelosi and
pelosi was like
i'm eating ice cream i'll talk to you in
six months
i'm glad we forced the issue said
senator susan collins the main
republican who along with senator joe
manchin democrat of west virginia or
leaders of a month-long effort to break
the impasse over pandemic aid even as
the virus exacted a growing economic and
health toll on the country
given the slender partisan divides that
will exist in both the senate and house
next year
the approach could provide a road map
for the biden administration if it hopes
to break through congressional paralysis
especially in the senate and pass
additional legislation
biden has said another economic relief
plan will be an early priority
no no no no is it this is supposed to
take us through march right
so what we don't need another economic
relief plan we don't and republicans
would do well to note this now okay this
was the last gap no more
and there will be no no more support
from the conservative base or any more
of these relief plans we understand our
relief plan is necessary
right now in many ways because of the
coveted shutdown and because of the
federal government's
unwillingness to actually open up
particular areas because it is a
state-based issue
and we get that there are times and
emergencies when
people just need the support and this is
sort of last-ditch effort although again
i would have preferred if congress had
simply said to the states this is on you
guys
you need to handle your own business
here you're handling all of the role
we're handling the vaccines because
that's a national level issue but when
it comes to unemployment insurance
really that should be a state level
issue like i wish the congress had said
that they didn't and they were never
going to
which means that they were going to pass
something here but if we get to march
right and we have had hundreds of
millions of people who have been
vaccinated and that has really started
with the most vulnerable in our
population and we're still talking about
covert relief
that is not correct okay so if if the
new york times thinks the republican
senate's gonna go along with that i
think they have
another thing coming nonetheless the new
york times
using this as a basis to push further
and further and further
mr biden on sunday applauded the
willingness of lawmakers to quote reach
across the aisle and call the effort a
model for the challenging work ahead for
our nation
he was also not an idol bystander in the
negotiations
yeah he kind of was mr biden on december
2nd through his support behind the 900
billion
plan being pushed by the centrist group
the total was less than half of the two
trillion dollars that pelosi and schumer
had been insisting on
yeah i'm sure that briden did throw
support behind that group but what
difference did that make
i mean as soon as the election was over
they were gonna pass something and
republicans had all the leverage because
republicans basically have nothing to
lose at this point it wasn't like
republicans were going to lose the
the presidential election it's over at
that point i love the new york times
but biden's brave guys mr biden's move
was not without risks
if it had failed to affect the
discussions the president's elect risk
looking powerless to move congress
before he had taken the oath of office
but members of both parties said his
intervention was constructive
and gave democrats the confidence to
pull back on their demands
so in other words they're now they're
now suggesting that joe biden stepped in
he said i want something passed and so
some of the more radical democrats
backed off
hey that was always going to happen
biden is not in control of his caucus
okay all that has happened here is that
biden recognized the reality and so did
democrats
that is all that doesn't matter biden is
the hero of the hour even though he
doesn't have any power
it's amazing the new york times like wow
what an amazing guy
michael flynn should go to jail because
he had an incoming conversation
as incoming nsa with the russians he
should go to jail for that but joe biden
is already impacting legislation
even though we are a solid month away
from the inauguration in january
well done everybody okay meanwhile when
it comes to coveted policy
anthony fauci is just saying things that
i i do not understand like under in
i seriously don't get it so fauci has
been suggesting that it's shut down time
like across the country we need lots
more shutdowns we need to make sure that
nobody travels during christmas
we need to make sure that if you get on
a plane to be with your family that's a
really really bad and dangerous thing
now he is not calling for flights
between the us and the uk
to close now the reason that people have
been talking about this is because
apparently
a new coven 19 mutation has been
spreading in the uk
is apparently up to 70 percent more
transmissible than the original version
which is i mean this thing is pretty
damn transmissible right so if you're
talking 70
more transmissible that basically means
that you walk into a room with somebody
they breathe and you get it
and we know that it's broken out in the
uk and already found she's like we don't
want internal american
flying like from new york to l.a or
something and now he's like you know
what maybe we shouldn't
halt the travel from the uk what i don't
i how is he the expert i just
why why you know i've talked to many
people in the private sector
epidemiologists in the private sector
and many of them have said like they
literally
they do not get the worship for fouchy
in fact some of them are rather
dismissive in the sense they said well
he works for the public sector which
automatically means he's not as good as
somebody who works in the private sector
like if you're really good he would be
working for pfizer he wouldn't be
working for the nih in any case
fauci said yesterday that he would not
shut down travel from the uk
which is like what i don't understand
like he he was saying that
maybe it's because this this strain is
is not more deadly than the strain that
is currently in existence
uh or that the vaccinations are already
rolling out yes but if you if everybody
gets infected
too fast for the vaccines that's sort of
the problem right i thought that was the
whole purpose
of pushing these sort of time and place
lockdowns in any case here's voucher
saying something that is completely
incoherent as researchers across the
globe scramble to study the new variant
a growing number of countries have
halted travel from the u.k
san francisco and santa clara counties
now require
a 10-day quarantine upon arrival u.s
officials still debating similar
restrictions
i think everything needs to be on the
table dr anthony fauci advising against
travel restrictions telling cnn
the u.s must keep an eye on it but don't
overreact to it
um what this is captain overreaction
right here like he overreacts in every
direction first it's like no one should
wear a mask and it's like everyone
should wear a mask until the end of time
first it's you know we should shut down
everything and it's like well we
probably should open the schools
and now it's like well we shouldn't shut
down travel from china well i'm
certainly glad we shut down travel from
china but we definitely shouldn't do it
from the uk like what in
the world what the hell is going on i am
extremely extremely confused by anthony
fauci's view
on this thing meanwhile to his credit
joe biden got the vaccine and he at
least gave some credit to the trump
administration which
it seems like he should considering that
operation warp speed is a trump
administration development
[Music]
i wish we had time to take you through
the whole hospital to see how
busy and incredible you all are and
we owe you big we really do
and one of the things is that i think
that
the administration deserves some credit
getting us off the ground
with operational warp speed okay so
you know at least he's doing that like
seriously give credit when credit is due
i will give credit to joe biden for
giving credit to trump that is that is
correct that is something that he should
do mitchell mcconnell also was
vaccinated
yesterday and he said that the leaders
of congress should take the vaccine i
mean number one they should take the
vaccine because they're all 97 years old
like mitch mcconnell is is a rather
elderly gentleman nancy pelosi is an old
lady like yes we should
yes those people should be taking the
vaccine i'm far more skeptical
that people like alexander ocasio-cortez
should be taking the vaccine here's
mcconnell talking about receiving the
covered vaccine yesterday
i think it's important for the leaders
in the country to step up
take the vaccine and help reassure the
american public because polls indicate
about
half the public is either skeptical
about taking the vaccine or doesn't want
to take it at all
that has to change because we can't
solve this problem
until large numbers of americans are
vaccinated
as a polio victim myself i fully
understand
the significance of vaccines it took
decades to develop the polio vaccine
this vaccine was developed
in under a year a modern medical
miracle and we need to take the vaccine
okay mcconnell should take the vaccine
i'll tell you who should not be taking
the vaccine is the young and healthy in
congress they're not more special than
you they're not more special than i am
they're not more special than anybody
i don't understand what just because
they're elected officials does not mean
they should receive the
vaccine first i don't know what's up
with today's show but this is the like
agree with people who i absolutely
despise the show
elhan omar actually said something
correct right she actually went after
other members of the squad
she said she said it would make sense if
it was age she's talking about members
of the uh of congress getting the
vaccine she said it would make sense if
it was age
unfortunately it's of it's of importance
and it's shameful
we are not more important than frontline
workers teachers etc who are making
sacrifices every day
which is why i won't take it people who
need it most should get it full stop
well again one of the worst people i
know making
an excellent point this actually happens
to be correct
tulsi gabbard said the same thing by the
way she said i'm not gonna take the
covet vaccine before the feds let the
elderly take it that's just ridiculous
here's tulsi gabbard yesterday
members of congress like me we can get
the vaccine before
at risk seniors can people like my aunt
who is imprisoned in her own home
because of the danger that if she
catches the disease
she could die this is immoral and
bad health policy i plan to take the
vaccine but
will now stand in solidarity with our
seniors by not doing so
until they can okay points to tulsi
gabbard she happens to be absolutely
correct about all this okay final piece
of news before we break for the day so
bill barr the attorney general
uh he did say yesterday that he's not
going to appoint an election special
counsel to
investigate voter fraud because he's not
seen any credible allegations of
widespread voter fraud
for all the crap that bill barr has
taken from the left this guy has at
least tried to be honest i mean this is
this is right
this happens to be correct if there been
widespread allegations of voter fraud in
these states it all would have been
adjudicated in the courts
and you know again there were cases
brought the only one that i'm aware of
that made serious allegations of voter
fraud
still being adjudicated right now are
the ones in georgia in many of these
states
the the trump campaign did not even
claim there was massive voter fraud
that's for example
wisconsin the pennsylvania cases did not
allege massive voter fraud here's bill
barr
saying there won't be a special counsel
to investigate the election in other
words we're done here legally
i think to the extent that there's an
investigation i think that it's being
handled responsibly and professionally
currently within the the department and
to this point i have not seen a reason
to
appoint a special counsel and i have no
plan to do so before i leave okay and
not only that
uh this i think is worthy of note so
newsmax which had really been pushing
very hard a lot of these allegations of
voter fraud voter irregularities sydney
powell
unleashed the kraken on newsmax when she
was talking the the former trump lawyer
and maybe future trump lawyer
had been talking about releasing the
kraken and all this kind of stuff well
now she said all that on newsmax newsmax
kind of went along with it
particularly when it came to dominion
because her kraken was the dominion
these voting machines they were hackable
in all of this
well dominion sent a legal modis to
newsmax and they said we are going to
sue you out of existence
we we are not we were not hacked there
are no serious allegations we were
hacked
smartmatic software is not even on our
machines we don't know the hell you're
talking about so you're gonna have to
retract that
this led to this huge walk back by
newsmax yesterday
newsmax has found no evidence that
either dominion or smartmatic owns the
other
or has any business association with
each other
we have no evidence that dominion uses
smartmatic software or vice versa
no evidence has been offered that
dominion or smartmatic used software
or reprogrammed software that
manipulated votes in the 2020 election
smartmatic has stated that its software
was only used in the 2020 election in
los angeles
was not used in any battleground state
contested by the trump campaign
newsmax has no evidence to the contrary
okay so just
that's a quick note even newsmax is
saying that at this point which means
the billbar
that's newsmax and again newsmax ain't
in the business of prosecutions
uh then um you know take bill barb and
his comments somewhat seriously
alrighty right after the show today head
on over to michael knows he'll be
discussing the covered relief bill in
more detail as well
as actor george takai suggesting that
republicans shouldn't receive
the vaccine later today matt walsh
hosted the matt wall show he will be
guest hosting this show's two additional
hours of content make sure to
come tune in for that as well i am ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show the
ben shapiro show is produced by colton
haas
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen